welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and while professor xavier and the
mysterious multiversal illuminati were
up in arms at doctor strange's various
light desecrations against reality a
zombie looking doctor strange was
literally floating up in multiple demon
arms at the very end of the big time
hype that was the second doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness trailer but
what the heck is going on here like is
this the zombie doctor strange from that
zombies episode of what if and did sam
raimi put those skeletons popping out of
the cloak of darkness just to scare me
personally i think the answer to that
last question is yes but let's speculate
on the rest of this mad multiversal
multi-armed magic mayhem together shall
we my nerd babies because i think that
there is a secret explanation here okay
so we know from the multiverse of
madness trailers that this film will
largely deal with the consequences of
what happens when you desecrate reality
as mordo puts it as well as the craziest
surprise from the first trailer being
that the biggest threat in the
multiverse was at least one variant of
steven strange himself likely multiple
variants of steven's truth and as we can
glean from all that recently released
promo material and posters it seems that
doctor strange too will be centering
around three main variants of doctor
strange our doctor strange who almost
broke the universe with a dauntless and
now auntless a racketed teenager that he
totally forgot about the long bearded
things just got out of hand rough
rough-looking dark doctor strange and
the mysterious red-clad defender strange
and it is the last of these three
defender strange that is the most
interesting of the bunch because it
seems that this red dress defender
strange is the very same doctor strange
variant that is dealing with all of this
dark magic that appears to be corrupting
his body causing his fingers and face to
get all dark and zombie-like from that
footage from the super bowl tv spots so
i definitely do not believe that this
fearsome flying freak flexing his fresh
new phalanges is the same or even a
variant of a zombie strange at all i
think he just looks like a zombie
because he's being corrupted because
remember when scarlet witch brings up
this excellent point in the trailer
about her becoming an enemy while
strange becomes a hero you break the
rules and become a hero i do it i become
the enemy
it doesn't seem fair i don't think that
she was referring to all the desecration
of reality that our doctor strange did
with that green infinity stone or a
spider teenager oh no that's mordo and
illuminati's beef with doctor strange i
believe that when wanda is talking about
strange breaking the rules she's
probably talking about the use of the
dark and corrupting red chaos magic that
even witches like agatha harkness and
all the girls of salem have grown to
fear and her discovering the absolute
unfair [ __ ] of a chaos magic
wielding defender strange getting a
freaking statue and global love and
recognition while she is being treated
like some type of unforgivable magic bin
laden when they both work together to
save the universe from thanos because
remember when she broke thanos freaking
helicopter sword and made him sweat like
where's that statue huh like i'd be
pissed too like what the heck this is
why i feel defender strange wears all
red similarly to the scarlet witch
because i have a feeling that this
defender strange dabbles in the red
chaos magic dark arts for the specific
purpose of some good old-fashioned
hogwarts defense against the dark arts
turn to page 394 it is this very mastery
of chaos magic in conjunction with his
regular magic that has caused him to
become so beloved by the world while
wanda maximov had to struggle to learn
of the dangers of chaos magic on her own
as the scarlet witch without the help of
commertaj's fancy libraries and
qualified teachers which is like super
unfair she didn't ask to be the scarlet
witch i never asked to be made because i
don't think mordo with the dreads is the
only person hunting down all of these
misbehaving multiverse shattering doctor
stranges because this doctor strange
variant probably has been as well likely
by absorbing all of the evil chaos magic
doctor strange variants into himself
much like we saw animated doctor strange
do when he used all that red chaos magic
in episode 4 of what if to absorb all
those other magical living beings that
he summoned on his path to becoming the
dark strange supreme and hey by the way
in honor of our most anticipated movies
of this decade our friends at epic hero
shop just released three new batman
theme shirts and two new sock designs so
that you could to creep around in the
night like batman and hey they normally
release new merch timed with the release
of the movie or show they're inspired by
but they're dropping this batman merch
early so that you could have it in time
for opening night just picture this
you're in line to buy popcorn and you
get a knowing nod from the guy working
at the register he leans in and whispers
hi i'm eric voss and now you just made a
cool new best friend for life who can
sleep you some free junior mints on the
side and our merch partners at epic hero
shop have all kinds of other cool
designs including two new shirts
inspired by new rockstar's favorite
memed out villain mephisto the demon
king himself epicura has all kinds of
new merch inspired by all of your
favorite properties and they're always
on top of the latest trends bubbling out
all the stuff that we're into at the
moment they've even got a trusted bro
moving company shirt that would look
great paired with a new rockstars zip up
fleece and yo sign up for their
newsletter at the bottom of their
website to get notified about all the
latest merch drops and check out all
their incredible products at
epicuroshop.com
epic hero be your own hero because let's
be real if even one doctor strange in
the multiverse has the ability to
harness the innate darkness of chaos
magic the lord knows just how many
doctor strange variants in the
multiverse went just as crazy as wanda
did and probably even more crazier
because that dude just doesn't know when
to stop because ever since the mind
stone amplified the latent chaos magic
within wanda's mind times like a
thousand billion the chaos magic has
been slowly driving her more emotionally
unstable over time with her first
appearance at the post-credits scene of
cap two being her just not doing very
well and looking kind of weird while
she's playing with those blocks she's
like i'm playing with blocks i don't
feel like my normal self because i
believe that this is because red chaos
magic is mcu's dark magic and likely why
the scarlet witch has her own chapter in
a book called the dark hold a book that
appears to be an encyclopedia of all the
dark and the damned of the mcu because
remember what happens to wanda when she
starts to use too much of her dark red
chaos magic in the one division finale
her hands and eventually the rest of her
body start to turn dark much like we see
defender strange turned dark in that
super bowl tv footage because i believe
that this is the moment that defender
strange realizes that he's bitten off
more chaos magic doctor strange variants
that he can chew and that all of that
dark magic he thought he could contain
within himself could not be contained
any longer with each dark set of arms
along with those scary screaming skulls
representing each chaos magic corrupted
doctor strange variant the chaos wizard
defender strange has been gobbling up
for the good of the multiverse and much
like we see strange supreme struggle to
contain the dark forces that he's
absorbed within himself with like little
tentacles popping out every now and then
i have a good feeling that this supposed
amazingly perfect chaos magic wielding
defender strange will have eaten one too
many a dark doctor strange causing him
to be unable to contain all the chaos
magic inside and thus be transformed
into the multi-armed multiversal
monstrosity at the end of the multiverse
of madness trailer a multi-armed
monstrosity that henceforth shall be
known as dark ah that's pretty good
but it's taken
wait wait i got it
mr misery because in the marvel comics
the doctor strange foe mr misery was
this huge glob of sentient darkness that
doctor strange creates as a result of
not wanting to bear the cost of the dark
magic that he was dabbling in for the
good of everyone in his reality because
instead of paying that bill when it came
due he literally tried to avoid the
check by shoving the darkness into his
basement like literally shoving it down
there but unfortunately over time that
dark thing in the cellar as it was
originally called became too powerful
and broke free much like i suspect will
happen within this defender strange
variant in doctor strange too and why
this zombie looking strange with the
arms looks a lot like mr misery does in
the first place and also potentially why
our doctor strange needs the scarlet
wish to fix all of defender strange's
arrogant mess because that's what doctor
strangers do they make messes and expect
other people to clean it up it doesn't
seem fair but that is what i think is
happening at the end of the doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
trailer what do you guys think let us
know in the comment section below my
beautiful nerd babies thank you guys so
much for watching this video you can
follow me at mastertainment if you want
to see me tweet some really weird [ __ ]
and really interesting theories but more
importantly you can follow new rockstars
wherever we are on social media thank
you guys so much for watching and i love
you guys times a million bajillion and
i'll see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you